[Music]
in touch my body news he's my favorite
singer that version cuz it's a guy
that's it he's a gay Korean guy
submitted by asianglow actually looks
pretty cute though yeah the end like the
round like never around
wedgie face and neck you're here keeps
get really red
I look like the anime cartoon when they
get drunk ready right here only got like
below yeah issued wear overalls and then
like put little freckles on and then
drink Jigglypuff Mariah Carey was served
a lawsuit by her former security guard
who accused her of humiliation and
sexual harassment what wait a second
this is different yeah cuz what's the
problem exactly
haha it's Mariah Carey my God he's gay
he's like Oh Kurt Mariah Carey are you
still like good current current Mike
yeah it doesn't matter because Mariah
what she's not disgusting not at all I'm
think so she's kind of fat right now big
but depending on Vic Watusi depending on
when she did it it's actually it's all a
blessing I know what I take that back
because I actually enjoy Mariah Carey
for her talent and her vocal cords are
fried oh she's amazing
I would be I'm highly offended right now
because her full she cannot say anymore
did you so she grabs your dick oh you
can't sing get off exactly hit that high
note hit that high see this is kind of
cool though cuz like we hear all these
uh
welcome outside this is kind of cool
because we hear all these stories of
dudes yep right like dudes abusing power
behind leaves about time a woman abuser
it's not really it's not really about
dudes it's people in power of use power
so it's cool to show the other side yeah
equality there are female harassers too
I want to hear a story about Barbara
Walters doing this I bet you she did I
want to hear story of 2020 JK Rowling
Jerome JK Rowling was like a super
social act to Harry Potter whoa Harry
Harry Potter's not real
you mean Daniel Radcliffe yeah yeah he's
Harry Potter to me okay okay okay ah
dude or she did that to gold
20 years later Ron Weasley comes out
it's like taking pro-league arrested me
he's so big though that guy he turned
out to be a giant who Ron Weasley dude
oh yeah ginger no yoked and [ __ ] nope
so anyways this Maria Carey former head
of security is claiming that she
sexually harassed him because during
this one trip to Cabo San Lucas which is
the sexual harassment capital is it I
don't no one's making [ __ ] up my name is
Guadalupe dilute it no he's not from
Cabo they went to Cabo like his name is
like has to start at the big Tyrone Big
Mike big Tyrone big chocolate big some
big name is Michael and mellow Oh Big
Mike
Big Mike it's Big Mike yeah so here's
Mariah and oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] that was
huge
well not that huge well she does heal
just crazy heals on though you kind of
look like a Joe Rogan and GSP had a PGS
pho role and Vin Diesel yeah all Vin
Diesel that's was thinking Joey's a lot
of masculine figures I love GSP but I
hate when that fool has to talk though I
do two men all these muscles disappear
that pull straight up
so bad yeah it's horrible it's like
they'll talk to GSP like what are you
gonna do how you been gone for four
years
you [ __ ] [ __ ] and he's like I am
going to win the French Kermit the Frog
yeah I've been trying to work done my
stand is good jump rope
my boxing is getting better and I like B
steps yeah yeah so Michael is claiming
that during this trip to Mexico that
Mariah asked him to go to her hotel room
to move some luggage and that when he
got there she was wearing a see-through
negligee open but she always dresses
like this well apparently like yeah her
boobs were hanging out oh my god what
was that and then Mikey tried saying
like oh you know come back later and
she's like no no I want you to move in
so she insisted on him moving the white
house that harassment then because she
was naked and then he didn't want to see
it but it was you did it was he married
and stuff I don't know he probably he's
probably married and she oh they do was
a single guy he might have been like he
could have been games so this company
the security company worked for Mariah
from June 2015 to May 2017 and they've
gotten stiffed on the balance of about
twenty two hundred and twenty one
thousand three hundred and twenty nine
well 51 cents so that's the amount that
Mariah still owes the company and also
the money they waited a little too long
he also promised Maria's team promised
the security firm another two years of
employment which would have been about
five hundred and eleven thousand dollars
so that's why they're there's this
lawsuit happening but as of right now
the lawsuit has been paused because it
seems like both sides are trying to come
to some sort of compromise so no yeah
does this we'll know that now he's not
gonna be taken seriously by any other
bodyguards in the entire world but if
we're gonna come out from seeing Mariah
naked and that's what you're complaining
about
well not only that but apparently she
kept calling the whole security team
like Nazis KKK and like all that like
just calling
we think that they belong to these
issues singing those words though yeah
this is kind of harder now that because
there's this dispute going on between
the two that day you know she owes them
money and whatever there's now it's like
now convenient comes out during all this
like sexual harassment or whatever it's
clear a person of power taking advantage
of someone that wants to get a role in
their film or something like that but in
this case it's like well the fact that
was a security company could fabricate
it to get the money or get something
back or whatever it just doesn't sound
clean yeah it's not clean all she did
was show up naked and hey can you move
this in her it's her hotel room yes last
year you're hearing about all these
other stories where it's like women are
being like forced to perform like oral
sex on these like men of power and
Sylvia I'm just saying in this instance
it's like the stories all he was she was
you know like that seems like a I'm not
shot back her up but as soon as I got a
story of like the seduction right
somebody tells you to come over here you
want to move my friend sure and they're
like look at me it's or not even that he
doesn't look like anybody she would want
to seduce ya the money like snake Hannon
yeah she likes like she's actually
dating my boy Bryan Tanaka the dancer oh
wow Libra she got the C's yes not even
she likes little Japanese boys what the
hell her type of home yeah young skinny
men yeah she don't like that type what
you think you think you that special
[ __ ] I don't know I don't know I guess
but like if you would flip the roles and
it was like him Nate like showing his
whole job telling like one of his female
staff members like move this and she's
like I'll come back later and I don't
think that's the the point that we're
making I think it's just a little
precarious that first of all there's a
lot of money behind it so mind you if it
was just that story then it's like if it
was just that story it's clearly he
didn't want that and she pushed it on
him yeah but then it's like oh by the
way they she also owes me half a million
dollars
seems like all of this is just in there
so it's the the fact that they owe money
the whole naked sexual harassment thing
the whole her referring to him as a
skinhead not seeing what saying is that
those things are being put out because
they didn't get their money no yeah so
I'm just saying everything that they're
accusing her of is all that and then
Plus that Michael is saying that she
claims that she didn't want any white
people around her she only wanted black
people so that's like another added
thing to this whole lawsuit that's what
she's like hired these people yeah so
that's a little and she's half like
exactly she only wants half of herself
around these people like how long was
this guy her security guard though uh he
was the head of the security so I guess
it's like a team from June like is it
his security company 2017 so that's like
two years
yeah I gotta hire people for two years
and like not want like certain races
around you know and then still say with
that so that's kind of it's like I'm
gonna hire you but I don't want you cuz
you're white but I'm gonna keep you for
like two years
yeah and seduce you things don't things
don't add up yeah just it all just
sounds like the security guy Mike he's
just Shady because nothing's adding up
where it seems like Mariah's the one
being like abusing power well I mean the
fact that she owes and menu though that
should have been the owner but that's
something that doesn't even need to make
it into the papers the sexual harassment
partial most people money all the time
like you just go to like small claims
court or whatever when you settle that
[ __ ] there's definitely a double
standard though like if a female and
power is harassing man and stuff and
whatever I think it's easy to be like
well especially if they're kind of like
a sex symbol or they're not bad-looking
it just it just it's easy to kind of be
like dude you're lucky and there's also
got to be like the consequence too it's
like hey if you don't like sexually do
this with me then you're gonna get fired
or you're not gonna do this yeah where
was the consequence you know understand
was it just like hey I'm here naked or
just like hey I'm here and they could do
something otherwise your entire firm is
gonna get fired not gonna pay your money
you know what I mean oh if there was a
consequence
like I'm not paying you cuz cuz you
didn't let me suck your dick yeah you
know that money what if that was the
punishment though she doesn't want to
pay me
she doesn't sound like but he would have
mentioned that right they're gonna bring
out a lawsuit you'd say like this is
also what happying versus just like dude
I was just like flirtatiousness I guess
yeah maybe she's just watching her naked
in her hotel room you know that could be
the case too though so she she has a big
ego cuz you know she could get any guy
that she want so then when she couldn't
get this guy she's like well [ __ ] you
then nobody hurts my pride this this
much and she's like I gonna pay you
cuz that's kind of weird that she
doesn't she's not paying like that part
is weird like she broke she's obviously
got money I've seen her house on MTV
Cribs that she's like a castle it's huge
like ten years ago
I know for me to say my opinion on this
because we've all masturbated to her I
think if you just put a regular hot
woman I would be on his side in a second
but it's Mariah Carey and I can't
separate my love for Mariah Carey and
this article well you masturbated to her
her voice I just need to hear the voice
I just want I just want the voice Bible
oh he put this big the speaker on his
ball sack hey hello vibrate help
technique so it's a little hard I'm a
biased so my opinion isn't I think for
most guys I think it's difficult to feel
sorry for another guy that's like 250
pounds this value because this sounds
like a dream company I don't think you
need to feel sorry for him I think it's
just like oh that's what's happening
okay moving on like I don't know what
else do you I feel because I feel sorry
I feel sorry for all the women that's
been my gosh they got a rats dick flat
and because I'm like oh [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] up dude
and then yet a suck dick to get a movie
role that's [ __ ] up
cuz you're already talented you don't
need that [ __ ] girl but then if it's a
guy it's very difficult for me
especially if the woman in power is
attractive but if she's like really like
nasty looking and I'm like oh dude you
had to go through some [ __ ] I mean you
should feel bad cuz not everyone like
yeah that's auntie she won't be there
and as you know the man's biology like
you're like da like it's easy it's not
like a hard place to be in but if this
if it goes against this guy's morals
like it's a [ __ ] up position to be put
in you know guard you can feel bad
there's also like professional integrity
right that he might be thinking about
he's like damn dude like this is my
business you know if I compromise this
that my business might be screwed moving
forward or with all of it as he's saying
there's he's stripping naked too damn
this is not every guy's a [ __ ]
scoundrel alright I know this what I'm
saying I'm just I'm just making that's
why I think just you know maybe that's
why it's hard for me to empathize
because my mind goes to the dark side to
the dirty side Guadalupe da Lupe
[Music]
[Music]